there's also been a lot of scrutiny
lately about the culture in Silicon
Valley the treatment of women in Silicon
Valley and some of the other big tech
companies as a leader you look at that
and say what what needs to change well I
think it's really important to continue
to encourage women to pursue careers in
STEM related fields but also to be a
part of the tech community when there
are more women in the tech community I
think things will most definitely change
I think being part of Facebook Instagram
has been an incredible experience of
Sheryl Sandberg is leading the company
and internally we have lots of
conversations about unconscious bias we
have lots of conversations about you
know supporting women and people of all
different kinds of backgrounds in the
workplace I think when there are more
women that helps I think having certain
programs is really important like we
have one that is called easy Ally which
helps men and women alike understand you
know how to overcome unconscious bias
how to recognize it when they see it and
how to how to deal with it so I think
that we have a lot of work to do and
this is something that we are most
definitely focused on and I am focused
on Instagram yeah but I've known you and
Sheryl long enough to know you guys are
talking about having more women and tech
companies for for a long time but that's
gonna take a while yeah I mean in the
meantime something else has to be done
and there does seem to be some sort of
cultural problem that exists well a lot
of times when people think about going
into tech companies they think about the
technical roles when I was growing up in
Cleveland Ohio if you had asked me if I
was gonna work at a tech company one day
I would have most definitely told you
know first of all Facebook didn't exist
at that time
Instagram didn't exist at that time we
didn't even have mobile phones so you
know that was a long time ago so I never
imagined that I would be part of a tech
company but when I try to help people
understand is that there are a lot of
really interesting roles in tech
companies that people of all different
backgrounds and
variances can have at a company where
they can add value at a company like
Facebook or Instagram and you know one
of my favorite stories is that there was
this woman who came to work at Instagram
first she was in one of these customer
Operations roles and what she did she
got inspired by the people who were
actually building the product and so she
taught herself how to code and then she
was hired as an engineer and she was one
of our greatest engineers so I think
that people can come into a company in
one way I was running policy and now I'm
in an operating or a business role at
the company and so there are lots of
opportunities for people to enter tech
companies it's a great I always say that
just to get your foot in the door mmm
it's like kind of company like just get
your foot in the door you'll figure it
out